let's see if we can learn a thing or two
about carboxylic acids
carboxylic
about carboxylic acids they have the
general form they still have that
carbonyl group just like we've seen in
aldehydes and ketones and they will be
part of a longer carbon chain but
instead of having a hydrogen here is the
case with an aldehyde or having another
carbon chain here with the case of a
ketone we have an oh group
just like that and you're probably
saying hey why is this called an acid it
must be called an acid because it is an
acid and it
you'd be right and the reason why it is
an acid and why it is more acidic than
just something with an oh group so the
reason why it is more more acidic it's
actually a good bit more acidic
than alcohols
is because once this thing loses its
hydrogen remember acids depending on
what type of acid you want to think
about acid in the lewis sense could be
an electron taker and this oxygen can
take the electron of this hydrogen or if
you think about the arrhenius definition
of an acid it is a proton donor and this
oh group can donate a proton it takes
away the electron of this hydrogen gives
away the proton either way but the
reason why this is more acidic than
alcohol is once it gives away this
proton it is actually resident
stabilized so let me show you what that
means and to do that let me actually
show you the bond between this oxygen
and this hydrogen
so the oxygen and the hydrogen
see the oxygen has that or the oxygen
has this pink electron and the hydrogen
has that purple or that magenta electron
right there if you put this in a
solution of water
so you have some h2o over here
you have some h2o
you have some h2o this oxygen right here
really wants to take back this magenta
electron so it can it really wants to
take back that magenta electron and as
it takes back that magenta electron it
would essentially donate the hydrogen
proton to a water molecule so the water
molecule would give one of its electrons
to the hydrogen proton and then become
positive so once this happens the next
step would look like this what was our
carboxylic acid will now turn into the
carboxylate ion
so it will now look like this
so it has our carbonyl group now this
oxygen just took an extra electron it
just took an extra electron so it has so
if i want to draw it i have that one
actually let me draw so this is the
oxygen to start off with the oxygen had
two lone pairs so i want to
draw those two lone pairs first so to
start off with it had those two lone
pairs and now it had it had this pink
electron from the get-go
and now it took this magenta electron so
now it has one extra valence electron it
has we could even draw them here we can
count them one two three four five six
six is this just a neutral oxygen but
now it gained another one it has seven
it now has a
negative charge and then the water has
now become the hydro has become a
hydronium ion
so you have the water
here we've increased the proton or the
hydronium concentration in the water
that's one water molecule is now a
hydronium molecule
so this is now bonded with
this hydrogen proton
just like this this oxygen gave away an
electron to this proton so now it has a
positive charge
and this right here this carboxylate and
this carboxylate anion
carboxylate
ion
right over here the reason why this
thing was a stronger acid than something
that just had an o h group is because
the the the conjugate base the
carboxylate ion is actually resonance
stabilized it is more stable than the
conjugate base of an alcohol and let me
show you that
this thing can share its negative charge
this
it can give an electron it can let me
draw it it can draw it could take this
magenta electron give it to this carbon
then this carbon will have an electro
extra electron so then it can give back
an electron to this top oxygen so then
it can give back an electron to this top
oxygen right there so it is resident
stabilized with this structure right
over here let me draw the same
so it could look like this
that's too big let me scroll down a
little bit
it could look like this
carbon
and now this took back this blue
electron so now that one of the bonds is
gone and it now has it started off with
two
with two lone pairs so i want to draw
that there
and now it has another lone pair it has
this electron this electron and now it
has that blue electron right over there
and now this oxygen this top oxygen has
a negative charge and now the carbon has
a double bond with the side oxygen
so now the carbon let me go back to the
yellow that's the first bond with that
oxygen it had one two
lone pairs to begin with and now it has
this magenta bond so this pink electron
is at this end and now this purple
electron is at the other end or this
magenta electron and now it has a double
bond with this oxygen and we know that
when you have resonance stabilization
it's not like you're going back and
forth the reality is is that the you
kind of have a half double bond between
both oxygens that the electrons are just
flowing across the whole place and that
stabilizes the molecule and so to show
that this is a resonance structure let
me put some
let me put some
brackets around it
let me put some brackets around it and
in general if this r group right here is
actually even better at withdrawing
electrons so if you put something that
was really electronegative here
something that likes to hog electrons it
would make the carboxylate ion even more
stable it would make the carboxylic acid
even a better acid so if you put
something electronegative here then you
could imagine that some of this negative
charge that we drew in these two
resonance structures can be sucked
can be sucked to that r group and then
that would make it even more stable and
would make the carboxylic acid even
even more acidic
now like in everything we've looked at
there are some common carboxylic acids
that are not systematically named that
it's probably a good idea to know and
i'll start with one and just to see the
pattern that we've seen in other things
i mean we've seen that
we've seen that this thing over here
if we have this
we call this
acetyl aldehyde
acetaldehyde
aldehyde this was the very simple
aldehyde we studied we saw that if we
have something like this
if we have something like this which is
a ketone
we call this acetone
acetone
so you could imagine what we're probably
going to name let me do this in a
different color what we're probably
going to name this molecule
this molecule right over here
this is a carboxylic acid clearly and it
has just that one methyl group just like
the acetaldehyde just like the acetone
and so this is acetic acid
acetic
acidic acid so the acetaldehyde acetone
and acetic acid for me are fairly easy
to memorize just because they all have
the acet part they all have that as
their prefix and this part of the
molecule is identical in every case and
the difference is the hydrogen the
methyl group over here or the oh group
making this one a carboxylic acid an
acetone and all of that now a couple of
other ones that it wouldn't hurt for you
to know
it wouldn't hurt for you to know is this
one right over here this is you could
argue even simpler than acetic acid and
this is formic acid
formic
formic acid and then another one and
actually i recently did a a general
chemistry video with this
where we did a titration example but
this is essentially two carbolic two
carboxyl groups attached to each other
it looks like
this
it looks like this two carboxyl groups
attached to each other and you could see
them there's this is one carboxyl group
right over here
and then you have another carboxyl group
right over here and so this actually can
be deprotonated twice this hydrogen can
be lost and that hydrogen can be lost
and this is oxalic
oxalic
acolic acid i'll leave you there and in
the next video we'll learn how to
systematically name carboxylic acids